Grab your spandex and listen up, because we
have an all-new season of "American Horror Story"
and Think Story is here to take
a deep dive into each episode.
I'm not gonna waste any of
your time, so let's get right into it.
We're in 1970, baby, at
beautiful Camp Redwood,
which, if you've seen the
trailer, doesn't turn out so well.
We're introduced to these
two, who we saw in the trailer,
and this dude and
his lambskin condoms,
because you never know when
a girl will be allergic to latex.
We hear the clanging of Mr. Jingles' keys,
who we've seen from the trailer is
supposedly the main bad guy this season.
Yes, we can confirm that we're in the middle of
camp season and these teens are camp counselors.
Notice also the grain in the film here,
which isn't shown in the 1984 scenes,
so if you ever see this grain,
we're likely dealing with a flashback
that mimics the style and
feel of an old 80's slasher.
We see this later on with the flashback
of Mr. Jingles working at Camp Redwood.
And as soon as this girl takes her top off, these two
are dead, which is officially the worst cockblock ever.
Here we get our first glimpse of the hand of Mr. Jingles and the sound of his keys, which we see here briefly.
And here's a shot of me watching
the final season of Game of Thrones.
Now, the creators make an effort to show
Jingles cutting off this camper's ear.
Serial killers have been known
to take tokens of their victims,
so expect these ears to come
into play later on in the season.
We also see the extent of the massacre
and that Jingles walks with a limp.
Now this makes sense since
many of the early slasher villains like Jason
Voorhees or Michael Myers walked very slowly,
so making Jingles unable to run is
keeping in line with that tradition.
But what is most revealing about this scene is
the exclusion of Leslie Grossman's character,
who we saw in the trailer as being in
that very cabin the night of the massacre.
We'll meet her a bit later on as the
owner of the camp, Margaret Booth.
Now, in my trailer video, I theorized that her character
is my number 1 pick of being the real or surprise killer.
And just this morning, I got a message from Twitter
user Cael Harden, who expanded on this idea that
Jingles is actually coming back to exact revenge
on Margaret and possibly to save the other campers.
The theory goes that he was framed for the
massacre and that Margaret was the real killer.
And so far, it's making a lot of sense.
She's a religious nutjob who decides to
reopen the camp where she almost died.
Her affinity to remain pure and
clean would also give her motive
to kill the philandering teens
at the beginning of the episode,
which coincides with the plots of many 80's
horror where a killer goes after horny teens.
Now we have our look at the new intro titles, which
can also give some interesting clues about the season.
Notice the 4:3 aspect ratio, which
is similar to those of VHS movies,
and the 1980's music
video style and retro graphics.
We also get a few shots of the camp,
but what I think is most revealing
in this is the inclusion of the ear.
But also of this ear with
sound waves going into it.
We've already seen that Jingles likes to cut off
ears, so pay attention to this in episodes to come.
Speaking of Jingles, we
also get this quick shot of keys.
And the 80's were huge with montages, so we get a quick 80's dance montage with our favorite son of Satan,
who is looking more like
the son of Richard Simmons.
Here we get introduced to our main cast:
Xavier, Montana, Ray, Chet and Brooke.
But it looks like both Brooke
and Chet are going to hit it off.
Montana remarks on Brooke
ogling Chet's, ahem, mound.
As I suspected in my trailer video,
she might be into girls herself,
talking about how
great Brooke's butt is,
but considering she used to
date Xavier, it's likely she's bi.
Brooke, however,
isn't here to hook up.
It looks like her character will be
that of the stereotypical slasher virgin,
a trope which I'm sure Ryan
Murphy will hopefully subvert.
In the lobby, Xavier
remarks about the Night Stalker,
a serial killer on the loose who
apparently stabbed someone 40 times,
almost decapitating his victim.
Chet introduces himself to
Brooke and she creams her pants.
We learn that Montana "rear-ended Xavier while in traffic", which is a very graphic double entendre.
Xavier is a method actor who trained
under the real acting guru Stella Adler.
And Ray met Chet at a party
where Justine Bateman was,
who was an actual actress known for
the 1984 show "Tales from the Darkside".
Summer is gonna be crazy
in L.A. due to the Olympics,
and Xavier suggests they all get a summer job
as counselors a few hours away from the city,
while Montana writes her number on
Brooke's arm in case she's interested.
While at home, Brooke removes her
earring, yet another reference to ears,
when she is later
attacked by the Night Stalker.
He somehow knows she has jewelry and
although his attempt at killing her is thwarted,
he says, "I will find you.
Satan will show me the way".
Considering how much last season focused on Satan,
I wouldn't be surprised if there's some crossover here.
Also, considering how we know L.A. has a satanist cult that was seen last season, who knows if they'll show up.
Rather than stay at home with the Night Stalker
still on the loose and knowing where she lives,
Brooke ventures off with the gang
and Montana gets a little close.
We learn that Chet was about to be an
Olympian when he was disqualified for drug use.
And for you young kids
out there, that's a polaroid.
Fuck, I'm old.
At a roadside gas station, we meet this lovely
character, Ed, according to his name tag.
And yes, he is Patrick Swayze's brother.
Notice his ring of keys here, which
Mr. Jingles will later take from him.
Xavier checks his voicemail on the
pay phone with what appears to be
a jealous ex lover
saying he's going to find him.
Could Xavier's ex be the Night
Stalker, which leads him to Brooke?
While seemingly lost on the
way, Xavier runs over this guy.
But what's mysterious is the fact
he says he can't remember his name.
Now, we don't know if this is the result
of him getting hit or if it happened prior,
since, as Xavier notes, he already had dried blood
and cuts that happened to him before the accident.
The hiker also says a menacing
line, "You gotta believe me, I tried."
So expect this to be expanded on later.
The counselors arrive at Camp
Redwood where we meet Margaret
and we're told that the kids are
supposed to arrive in the morning.
But first things first, they got
to get this hiker to the infirmary.
There, they meet Rita, who tells them
she used to work at Hawthorne Hospital.
Now might just be coincidence, but the Hawthorne School for Exceptional Young Men was where
Michael Langdon was trained and where
most of the events of Apocalypse take place.
They lie to Rita, saying they found the hiker on
the side of the road when they actually hit him.
Margaret then shows
them to their quarters.
We get a few shots of the lake
and an introduction to Chef Bertie,
who was around when
Margaret was just a camper.
This is our first indication that Margaret was
indeed a camper before she reopened the camp
after "One bad apple ruined it",
a reference to Mr. Jingles and the massacre.
Margaret tells them that the girls shower
in the a.m. and the boys in the p.m.
And we've already seen in the trailer
someone peeping at one of the male's showering,
who I surmise, due to eye color, as being either Xavier or Matthew Morrison's character, who we'll meet in a bit.
After Margaret shows them to their
cabins, we learn that she's a religious zealot
who fights "the Lord's fight against filth".
She stood alongside Charles Keating, who
was a real-life anti-pornography advocate
famous for his crusade against Larry Flynt .
And we learn her husband died, leaving her with
a fortune, which she used to reopen the camp
and make it a godly
place for children to escape.
Very convenient for her husband to
die and leave her with all this money.
Around the campfire, Rita tells the
counselors about the Camp Redwood massacre,
which happened 14 years ago.
And we get a little bit of an origin story
for Mr. Jingles aka Benjamin Richter.
Apparently, he was a Vietnam veteran
who collected the ears of his kills
and became somewhat of
a groundskeeper at Redwood
when one day he snapped,
murdering all the female counselors.
There was one survivor, however, Margaret,
who says through the power of Christ
was able to leave her body while she was
having her ear sawed off as to not make a sound.
She hopes that by
reopening Camp Redwood,
she can turn the dark memories she
had into something bright and happy.
The hiker awakens in the middle of the
night and checks himself in the mirror
to find out that he
has also lost his ear.
Now, this has happened
before Jingles' arrival,
so there's obviously someone
else perpetrating these acts.
Brooke decides to check
on the hiker, or so she says.
I can't help but feel she's in that
infirmary for a different reason.
She's startled by the hiker, who tells
her that the phone lines are down,
because it wouldn't be an
80's slasher if they weren't.
And when she tries to comfort him, he seems
confused that Camp Redwood has reopened.
Back at the cabin, we're introduced to
everyone's favorite Glee teacher, Matthew Morrison.
He plays a character named Trevor, who was cut
from a Jane Fonda video for being too distracting.
"That thing was flopping around
like a baby elephant's trunk."
It's skinny-dipping time, and Trevor and
Montana are already breaking Margaret's rules.
They're interrupted by an impending
storm and a pair of spooky headlights.
Now, we haven't seen Jingles arrive
yet, he arrives later when it's raining.
So my guess is that this is someone
else, likely Margaret keeping tabs on them.
We're then introduced to Dr. Hopple in what appears
to be a scene straight out of 1978's "Halloween"
with a patient, Mr. Jingles, having escaped.
3 hours earlier, he killed an orderly and
escaped, taking his glasses and keys with him.
We learned earlier that Ray is also an orderly, so
it will be interesting if there is a connection here.
Hopple inspects the cell to find a newspaper
clipping about the reopening of Camp Redwood
with Margaret's picture circled in blood.
Jingles is going back to Redwood
to put an end to its only survivor.
Or perhaps to seek
revenge, if the theory is correct.
Back at the gas station, Ed works on a car,
and take a look at these delicious hot dogs.
And you know, if you're underneath a car in
a horror show, this isn't gonna turn out well.
Mr. Jingles completely
destroys him and takes his keys.
Also note that Jingles has killed 2 people so far
and hasn't taken either of their ears as tokens.
Chet goes full roid rage after seeing the opening
of the Olympics and is pissed he isn't there.
He throws a crushed beer can
at Ray, who gets a massive cut,
and Rita refuses to help
because she's the worst nurse ever.
- "Nurse, a little help?"
- "I clocked out already. I'm here for the kids."
Brooke looks after Ray and
they share a little moment here.
So if we go by the horror trope
that the virgin character will survive,
it usually means her love
interest is one of the first to go.
So watch out, Ray.
Brooke says she'll look for some iodine and
bandages, when she notices the hiker hanging out
with the sound and image of what
appears to be Mr. Jingles watching her.
We don't see the perpetrator's face here, which
leads me to believe we're dealing with the second killer,
someone who is
motivated to keep the hiker quiet.
But this character has a
limp and you can hear the keys,
so it's either one of three things:
Margaret trying to keep in character,
Jingles trying to save
Brooke from the real killer,
or I'm just thinking way too hard on this
and it's simply Jingles trying to kill her.
As Brooke runs, I love how it's juxtaposed
with the lighting of the Olympic torch.
She tells the other counselors what she saw
and when they go to investigate, they find nothing.
Also, Montana has
the worst shield ever.
And look who's there to usher
them back to their cabins?
Margaret, who just so happens to be
in a similar raincoat to Mr. Jingles.
Brooke seems to be the only
one noticing this phone ringing
and wakes up Montana, who
we find sleeps with a switchblade.
You know that switchblade
is gonna come back.
Brooke ends up answering the phone
when we hear the clang of Mr. Jingles' keys
and see the arrival of the Night Stalker.
This is accompanied by Brooke
asking the person on the phone who it is
and if you listen carefully, you
can hear the response "Satan".
We know the Night Stalker is a
follower of Satan, so this makes sense.
That's it for my
episode 1 breakdown, guys.
I am super pumped about this season.
I think it was a fantastic first
episode, set up a lot of stuff,
but I want to hear what you thought
about it in the thoughts below.
Make sure to give the video a like
and subscribe with the bell on,
as I plan to do
breakdowns of every episode.
You can also follow me and send me
theories to my Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Until next time remember,
Daddy loves you very much.